le tropisme à son apogée bornes et
vindicatif omniprésent impartiale avec
les voix discordantes donald trump
montre un visage radicale de sa manière
de conduire les affaires publiques
les tergiversations du président
américain face à cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent sont devenus monnaie
courante à washington nous parlons d'un
vaccin peut être un remède c'est
possible donc on verra ça mais nous
parlons d'un vaccin et ils avancent très
vite toutes les entreprises
pharmaceutiques avance très vite toute
personne qui a besoin d'un test peu en
ferrain ils sont tous prêts ils les ont
à disposition
en plus de cela ils en font des millions
d'autres au moment où nous parlons il me
semble que si nous faisons un très bon
travail
nous maintiendrons le nombre de morts à
un niveau plus bas que si nous ne
faisons pas du bon travail mais les gens
parlent de juillet août quelque chose
comme ça nous pourrons sauver des vies
les plus vite nous pourrons remettre les
gens au travail à l'école et à la
normale une chronologie de déclarations
infondées qui a rendu plus que difficile
le travail de cet homme
anthony fochi conseiller médical de la
maison blanche depuis plus de 30 ans cet
expert mondialement reconnue des
maladies infectieuses doit composer avec
la personnalité de donald trump à
plusieurs reprises il a dû en finesse
mais publiquement ont recadré le
président des états unis et rectifier le
tir après ses propos approximatifs ou
erronées je marche sur une ligne de
crête je dis les choses au président qui
n'a pas envie d'entendre
et j'ai déclaré publiquement des choses
différentes de ceux qui l'assurent
je ne veux pas le mettre dans l'embarras
ni jouer les durs je veux juste donner
les faits une rigueur qui ne fait
qu'accentuer l'amateurisme du président
au sujet de la science et qui ne date
pas d'hier
le washington post en janvier dernier
publié un décompte pour le moins
vertigineux au troisième anniversaire de
son arrivée au pouvoir donald trump
avait annoncé 16 1241 mensonge ou
affirmations erronées selon le journal
américain
il semblerait que le constat soit à
nouveau vérifié l'ambition politique de
donald trump
semble parfois primer sur les enjeux de
cette crise sanitaire d'où son
impatience face à la mise à l'arrêt du
pays
j'ai eu de nombreuses discussions avec
mon équipe et des experts de renom et
nous sommes très près de finaliser un
plan d'ouverture de notre pays
avec un peu de chance même avant la date
prévue ce qui est très important
le gouvernement fédéral a un pouvoir
absolu il a le pouvoir
nous verrons si j'utiliserai ce pouvoir
imposer son autorité fédérale pour
ouvrir l'économie une volonté
significative de montrer qui tient les
rênes du pays
une autorité remise en cause par les
gouverneurs ce sont eux qui ont ordonné
le confinement dans leur état et notre
président ce serait donc à eux de
décider de la réouverture
cette passe d'armes pourrait également
miné la crédibilité du chef de l'état
aux yeux d'amérique et indirectement
menacé sa réélection preuve en est 57%
des américains approuvent l'attitude des
gouverneurs face à la pandémie
seuls 38% ont la même opinion de la
réponse fédérale